okay so this tutor is gonna be an LP
with PI torch we're gonna do some recap
on NLP basic of neural nets and then
we're gonna go further in the second
part into more recent developments in
NLP hopefully gives you a sense of how
do you build more recent deep learning
networks to train those models so before
we start here's the link to the slides
and there the second link is to all the
notebooks so it's hosted on github I
also posted it in a stack channel of
tutorials where you can just go directly
and then also on that github you have
the link to the slides okay I'm just
gonna quickly show you how you're gonna
open up collapse and run your notebook
with it
github mm-hmm search for stout feet
and then make sure that you're on the
develop branch here we have to update
the notebooks you can see here there are
six different notebooks that we can run
through you can just click one of them
and then I will show you how yeah so we
specifically make the notebooks in a way
that it doesn't take too long to run so
you can while we were given your slides
you can run it on this side as well and
what is really good is that it also
gives you a runtime of the GPU so you
can disconnect and then you're connected
to a GPU which takes much faster to run
through all the selves
good so click this claim er so we won't
be have the time to run through all the
notebooks one by one but you can run it
on the side as follows through the that
the steps I just showed you
yeah and let's get started so I'm
Jeffrey that's two Zanna my teammate
we're both data science people in Scout
B and our 5 second promotion
we're a I powered b2b sourcing platform
in Germany where startup we are very
data science bias so we're always
constantly looking for data enthusiasts
deep learning people Python engineers
we're fully python-based check out Scout
be calm all right
so prerequisites and goals we assume
that you have some machine learning
exposure and then you're somehow
intermediate Python coder or you use
Python late today yeah and you
understand what the basics of neural
nets so that when we're introducing the
PI torch way of building neural nets
it's easy for you to follow the ghost of
this is that we want to go go give you a
recap of deep learning and then take
that part to the second where we can say
how do we help you build a deep learning
based NLP model more recent developments
for instance like sequence to sequence
models or trans doing transfer learning
fine tuning etc ok that's going to be
the outline so the first part is gonna
be introducing PI torch some of you
might have already known these things
static versus dynamic basics and then
we're gonna do recap on the neural nets
how do you train a basic fee for network
at PI torch define your loss functions
do gradient descent etc we're gonna also
do it slight recap on NLP basics
but also in pi torch and how do you do
tax pre-processing how to represent your
text into a discrete space etc and then
we're going to more recent stuff how the
continuous representation works with
embeddings then we're gonna do iron urns
which are sequence models how does it
work
different types of that how do you do
text generation or sentiment
classification and we do the more recent
sequence models which happens within
these two years those models are then
the basic of recent developments you see
in transfer learning so things like GP
d2 and Bert etc and it give you a basic
understanding of why is it useful okay
so Susanna is gonna go start with the PI
torch intro price which works and where
PI torch fits in the overall deep
Learning Library ecosystem okay so this
is a cool graph karpati put on his
Twitter it might be kind of hard to see
but the purple one the dark purple one
is hi torch so is this line here and
then we also have tensorflow
which is the pink one at the top so you
see since our flow is still very
dominant and academic research for deep
learning but pi torches on the rise and
of course this doesn't include 2019 in
the year into 2018
so the to talk about deep learning
libraries we first want to talk about
what they do like what's their primary
objective so we want to be able to
define a model a loss function some kind
of optimizer
so we want to define how our matrices
process and how the model is set up to
learn and then we want to also support
automatic differentiation which is back
propagation so we have this ecosystem
where we have a bunch of these deploying
libraries you might recognize some of
them high-torque is the one that
responds if you don't recognize the
updated logo yeah so a common factors I
think differentiates these two the most
in terms of how their API is structured
is whether they are a oh yeah they're
this whether they are a static versus
dynamic
deep learning library so if you look on
the green those are dynamic so this
includes pie Georg dinette chainer and
then the more traditional ones with
sensor flow care osteon oh I guess it's
more outdated now h2o for
it's all static computation graphs so
when we talk about those what's the
difference so for a static computation
graph the whole idea is that we define
how we want to have our model flow and
then we run it so it's kind of like it
has this kind of like compile step to it
so we define everything first and then
we feed data into it so there's actually
some good advantages of doing it this
way this house tensor flow works is
where we can is easier to distribute
this and it's also nice it's but it's
more complex to code this because it's
it doesn't work with your intuition
especially with Python being a dynamic
language interpreted language that we
would imagine that the deep learning
library API would also be more dynamic
so dynamic is defined by run instead of
defined and run so our computational
graph of how we want to transform my
matrices is defined on the fly so we
want to be able so a nice thing about a
church is that we can just throw a
debugger anywhere and be able to look at
what our matrices look like what the
dimensions are you can't do this so
easily in sister flow and there's some
nice things you can do with those kind
of models and there's also you're able
to do some more complex kind of networks
that you wouldn't be able to do and
sister flow but it's mostly it's a lot
more pythonic to do it that way because
it's interpreted language and yeah okay
so hi torch is a deep learning library
in Python so you can kind of think of it
as India razo GPU support India arrays
being in numpy so it looks a lot like
numpy arrays but you can do gradients on
them yeah so does automatic
differentiation optimization and
has these dynamic computation graphs so
just a little bit of a feel for the pie
chart syntax so we can create tensors
just like that so you created since
there it's kind of just like an umpire
ray we can do support broadcasting so if
we do two times that it will broadcast
it to each element so that's quite nice
we can also send our tensor to device
that device could be your CPU or it
could be the GPU so kudos for the GPU so
what's cool about Pi search is that we
can define some variables here so we
have X and some so we just have some
variables at the top and we have weights
and we require gradients to calculate on
our weights and then we type some more
code and this graph starts to get more
filled up so we do some matrix
multiplication tour shot mm it's matrix
multiplication so we have these
operations and we're able to start
building our graphs and then we keep
adding some operations and then we even
add this other line so you can see this
computation in the graph is being
generated on the fly as we define our
code instead of all in one step and then
if you want to do the backpropagation
and you just do this dot backward
command okay okay so we're gonna talk
about a little bit of then how do you
use pi towards what she just showed into
building a very basic fee for network so
a bit of recap on neural nets or any
model specifically you have your inputs
which is your training data if you did
into the model which can black box feet
for network sequence Network whatever a
generates a prediction given that a
probability probability guess of that
model or a regression that is a number
and you use your target which is
basically the truth versus this
prediction and you try to access how
wrong is my model prediction on that
so generally your loss function ideally
the lower the the better that means your
prediction probabilities very in sync
with what the target distribution is and
then you try to do some weight update
with that you try to say how do I go
down this hill so that how did I change
my parameters so that my loss would go
down the hill we look at it from a math
side like assume like a basic linear
regression problem you do matrix
multiplication so that you predict a
very linear output from the X input you
give your predictors Y hat and normally
use a routing routing square error or in
this case a mean square error to access
how different is my prediction versus
the target and you do gradient and I
update your weight so that's how it
looks like as a basic fee for network
you have your inputs and then your feed
through hidden states you do activation
on each of the each of the layers so
that it can fit to any learning
non-linearity in the world what is very
useful about deep learning networks is
that there's this universe approximation
theorem that if you stack multiple
layers together they can actually
approximate any function any nonlinear
function in this world so in the end you
just need to stack more and more layers
so that that model general is better
towards different ranges of input
and you have different kind of love
last functions here we show all kinds of
common loss functions and loss is
important that it tells you how wrong
your model is so that gives your model a
guideline of how should I update my
weight so for instance if you're talking
about regression problems you probably
mostly use l2 loss which is the linear
regression kind of lost I just showed
you if you're talking about
classification kind of problems where
the output is basically a prediction of
the probably down the class then you can
use negative negative likelihood
basically it's a synonym for maximum
likelihood estimation or cross-entropy
which is actually optimizing the KL
divergence so that it goes lower you can
use each other and one is regression the
other one is for a classification
throughout this tutorial mostly if we're
predicting for a class we'll use cross
entropy for it okay so how exactly do
you do go by that and PI torch you
initiate class this is already built in
so an N is actually module within pi
torch that you can just call and I said
I want cross entropy loss this gives you
this class and then when you're
calculating your your loss then use the
prediction versus the your prediction
for model versus the target you can feed
it also the batch so that your emphasize
is then the batch number by one access
and then the other size their prediction
and then I calculates to these
predictions and give you the cross
entropy estimate for it so that's your
prediction and then that's your target
your truth and then when you're doing
gradient descent after you have built
this computational graph in your models
you want to update your learning rate
you want to update your parameters so
you set the learning rate which
the dynamic or can be static and right
now everyone use dynamic for instance
optimizers like Adam that tunes that and
it goes by the your surface has lost
pretty well but PI torch does it for you
so you have a lost surface which can be
in this case to two parameters it can be
undone dimensional space where you have
a surface in this hyper space and you're
trying to find the position on this
graph that low minimize your loss and
we're projected to 2d the ghost like
that you want your model to be able to
after each train after a [ __ ] parameter
update you want your model to be able to
walk slowly down the hill till the point
where is the minimize and loss that
means your model is actually doing a
good job of predicting the target and pi
torch what you do is quite straight
forward so you have to find your lost
function and you're feeding your
prediction versus your target to get the
loss which is a scalar which is a number
and you do backward which is actually
taking gradient of this loss the scalar
loss versus the computational graph
within your computational graph you are
ready to find the weights so the W's
before your ex is your input your w's
your weights your predefined these
weights so that when you call backward
it's actually gonna compute the gradient
on the fly and I store those gradient on
the variables and then the second step
is then you call optimizer does step
because when you initiate your
optimizers are already knows that which
are the parameters I will want to update
for each of the gradient so it actually
multiplies the learning rate which in
this case is dynamic with the gradient
that you have applied to on the
variables and then updates the weight
for you so that's it
actually four lines of code you define
your computational graph which is a
matrix multiplication define your loss
you've reading your prediction and then
you just let pi PI torch do the rest
okay so if you're training if you're
writing your own fee for in your net I'm
gonna show you how you can write with a
few to three basic class then you can do
your own fee for predict fee for network
that's how you will actually take your
data set in Python you can load it with
pandas or something and then how do you
transform that into a object that PI
torch can understand you initiate a
class depending on what your data set is
in this case is our data set and you
inherit the class from data set which is
from PI torch building within in it when
you're initializing it you can do
whatever operation you want on top right
so I read my pandas dataframe I
tokenized my words I do transformation
into vectors etc those operations and I
store on this class so that when I call
the class it returns me the input and
the target and you will always need to
define these two methods for the class
it's by default required by PI torch so
that you can call item by index so I
initiate my my data set as an object and
when I do index like a square bracket I
0 it gives me the first record that's
what get item is does for you and then
you have to write one for for length so
that when you call land by the data set
that gives you how many records you're
actually having within this day yes and
that's how you initialize it so you just
call my data set maybe you were feeding
a path where you want to read your your
Python file 5 I'm sorry where you want
to read your data file and then you can
index tall by index or you can call my
size yeah
okay so now we so now you have load at
your data how do you do your models and
that's a based very basic fee for
network it looks like in pi torch it's
inherited from a different class and in
the module is basically mirror net
module so I said I want to create my
first classifier yeah which is a binary
classifier of 0 & 1 when I initialize it
when I initialize it I give it three
layers FC 1 FC 2 and C 3 they're all the
inner layers you see by the size of the
brackets actually telling it which is my
weight size by default since you're
calling linear layer PI torch understand
this not as numbers but as variables
numbers are things that don't change
while you do in differentiation or
somehow things like your input like your
target you don't want your model to
update your input data or update your
output data variables are things that
you can train so if you call requires
grad equals truth on any variable that
you have defined that PI torch will
interpret like if I have a computational
graph I've been doing a backward pass on
it I can update those values and linear
layer is one of those so essentially
you're initiating three attributes or
objects underneath this my classifier by
size of 128 32 and then with the second
pass I want down from 32 to 16 and down
to 1 1 means it's 1 or 0 so and then you
have a second forward path method which
means I initiate my class which is my
model and then you said model input data
then it's gonna go through the forward
pass this is where PI torch actually
build up this dynamic computational
graph and it calls it by sequence so you
say I take the input I feel free
through the first layer I give it a
nonlinear activation call relu which is
a rectifier you can Google rectifier
it's basically taking the max between
zero and the value so actually did sell
all the negative values take those input
it's already a nonlinear output freely
through a second layer does the same
thing and then feed it through the last
layer and the output size I give a
sigmoid activation which basically
outputs between 0 & 1
bounded and that's my computational
graph when I initialize this class by
that and I said to CUDA means is sending
to your GPU yeah and you can send it to
2 device you can initiate your device
and I send it to device it tells your
GPU that there's this model available
that since all your permit parameters to
GPU and then when you do model and
you're feeding your own inputs it's
gonna call the forward pass which
basically builds up the graph okay so
you have your data set loaded you have
your model computational graph built
let's see how do we do training on top
so you said you define number of epochs
that you wouldn't want to Train in this
case 10 for instance make it faster and
the loader is basically this data set
that you have prepared so you split that
your data set into batches say each
batches I found about 512 records so
your inputs and your target is going to
be both a tensor of batch size versus
the input size I called yeah I already
initialize my optimizer so you Adam and
I tell my initializer that I told my
optimizer that please zero out all the
gradients of the variables because I
don't want the previous runs gradient to
affect what I'm trying to do right now
so our zero that out and I do the for a
path it's simple as after
initiative model used a model give it an
input and predict output which is in
this case also in the same shape of
batch lies and your prediction so you
take your target flashlights prediction
batch size truth and batch size
prediction you feed it through your loss
function you get the loss which is a
scalar and you do backward when you're
called backward pi torch does this
gradient descent gradient for you
automatically so it does automatic
differentiation of that and then you
call optimizer that step
those two number of epochs as you
defined and then update those weights so
that goes down the hill and that's
pretty much it when for how you put a
very basic fee for network oh yeah so go
through that okay so now I'm gonna do a
very quick breeze through of NLP basics
basically how do you do
text reprocessing and then how do you
use pi torch in the case of NLP some use
cases where the real world NLP is using
for instance language comprehension
things like audio or my speech to text
and interpreting that text for instance
I Alexa or say Alex a please Google
something understands that understand
your speech turns that into text and
understand that text in this talk we're
gonna focus mostly on text to text or
text classification kind of problems so
we don't do audio files that much here
second use case machine translation so
yeah use Google Translate for instance
you have a text and your output is a
text in this case which were we were
introduced later how do you turn this
sequence into a different sequence and
then text generation or give us some
text as a seat and you try to let the
model start run write writing its own
article or for instance summarization
and give a very long text can you find
the most important parts of that
text and then use language model to
generate a summary that makes sense
yeah my Google News you see those like
headlines or so named entity recognition
this we use it a lot as Cal P so we
actually get a lot of those free text
from everywhere but when we're trying to
identify what is what I does is it a
company name is it a product name is it
etc it's all embedded within all these
like full text from the websites and
Andy are actually does it for you so it
does tagging for the positions that it
says this is a the class that you want
to that you have to find it for so this
is a company name then we can extract
that part out of that so it's a lot with
information extraction sentiment
analysis things like is it a positive
review or a negative review am I happy
with my text review etc so this is this
is focusing on the text classification
which will also introduce okay so say
you have your free text long range of
text and how do you turn that into this
data say that I introduced my torch and
then you can run your model on top so
first thing your tokenize it your
reading your file and you have one
column which is like all these full text
descriptions of some company so first
thing you tokenize it if you're we're
talking about Western languages this is
mostly how you would do to organization
covering things like meandering Japanese
or so on there they're different and
then you would try to remove stop words
because those things stop words are
things like a D B et cetera those things
gives you very low signal they're
everywhere so this gives you very low
information aware of the text you should
focus on if you just take the frequency
those words is gonna be ranked on top
but then it's going to bias your model
it's going to
think that's important but it actually
tells you nothing because in every text
you have DOS so you remove things like
be out of this this sequence of tokens
and then you'll lemma ties it so what
you want as your vocab is to be as
sizable as possible so that so that when
you meet a new text you wouldn't see a
lot of unknown text unknown tokens
inside that but still you don't want
your size of vocab to be too large so
that you only have one occurrence of
that text that for that your model
wouldn't learn nothing so in English for
instance you have all these past tense
you have multiple like s in the end you
have different cases for the word we try
to find the stem of the word so you
would lemma ties it in this case that
jumped the past tense becomes the
present tense jump with that when you do
in your vocabulary or vocab or will
become like you will get a higher like
overlapping between the words on
different training sets and I probably
will replace real words you want you try
to limit your vocab size so that only
like things were occurs very frequently
I got captured so your mask out things
like sneaky for instance if that's not
happening very frequently so you count
your whole corpus what's the frequency
about these words and they're trying to
limit your vocabulary what you see here
that the sneak has a y in the end there
is a way of masking out so that we're
not losing our information we're not
taking all the real words and say this
is an on token we try to bucket that
into things like things having Y in the
end maybe tells you a bit or two things
have a are in the end tells you a bit or
two so you have several different
variations of unknown tokens still
remaining your corpus but they're just
masked out so they are things all having
Y in the end what all goes to the same
bucket will be replaced with death and
that's pretty
but your pre-processing and then now you
what you want to do is then how do I
turn this sequence of tokens into a
representation like numbers so that my
model can understand and the most most
classical one my traditional one is a
discrete representation so what things
call one hot encoding with generally our
vocabulary so you do your pre-processing
and then you get all the unique words
this is basically the vocabulary the
things that your model knows that this
is a word is another unknown word and
you take your text sequence which is on
top and you say for this word where's
the position of that so in every column
you just have 1 1 1 all the rest is 0
there's one is called 1 hot what you get
out of that is a first numerical rapist
representation of this text right you
have your corpus which is this sentence
and then for each of the word you encode
it like a one hop vector but then how do
you know how this corpus is similar or
different than the other corpus that you
have say you have two sentence and you
both do this one hot encoding it's a
matrix so then you will do bag of words
representation what you do is you take
your one Hunter encoding and you sum by
this direction by your vocabulary
direction so that in different position
if you hit the same work then account
increase this basically becomes that
that's your bag of words vector and this
vector represents this corpora this text
you're inputting so it says on is one
occurrence there's no tour occurrence I
see two times gray I see two times the
etc yeah but note that the normally you
would already strip off during when
you're pre-processing it because you're
removing your software it's and while
you get in Python is in the end like a
dictionary
so you have formed a word tutor
occurrences you may also do indexing so
that you generate your vocabulary by the
word token towards index and just use
the index to reference the count this is
the descriptor discrete representation
of your text but it also has flaws so it
wouldn't be able to understand synonyms
if words are different say a cat and
kitten or a dog versus a hound the
representation will be different and it
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
because your model thinks is two
different vocabulary that's why is a
discrete representation you wouldn't be
able to project the words into a
continuous space and get the similarity
between those we will talk about that
later but for now this is a kind of easy
comprehensive understanding of what the
composition of the text is so you can
use things like a scalar and which is
not even pi torch you can count
vectorizer it gives you that
automatically okay
so we can actually use this bag of words
vector and use that to predict
sentiments like taking the movie reviews
with pre-process that turn it into bag
of words each of those reviews turn it
into bag of words representation and use
that feed through a basic PI torch
network I PI torch before Network and
use that to say is it a positive review
or a negative review so you have
examples like those all the inputs are
this bag of words representation that we
talked about like you see in the first
example 2 times of good 1 times movie
one time of interesting it's very likely
that this is a positive review and you
have things like terrible or hated that
occurs frequently then it's likely that
is a negative review what you do you
take the bag of words representation
which is basically a sequence a number
and the size of that vector is always
your vocab size each of the index the
size is a vocab size each of the indexes
stay in the count of that word we think
that that text and those numbers you
feed it through they're fully connected
network that we showed before like the
class you can initiate different number
of layers as you want and then your
output basically is still 0 1 so you
will feed it through a sigmoid
activation to get the probability
prediction or in this case you can also
get the logit because pi torch does it
for you you count the loss generate this
lost gallery lost value that based on 0
1 versus the prediction probability and
then you do back backward back
propagation with it and that's your
first text classifier so let's see how
you do it exactly all right
so you can open collect and then load
this first notebook into it I won't run
it on the fly but I've already generated
the outputs for you so these are just
the packages you need you see like n n
functional etc so these are the
preparations for it basically you
download the text and that's how the
text looks like as your raw data so you
have one column which is basically the
reduce is full of text and then you have
the label 0 and 1 what we try to do we
take this we try to take this and then
do a bag of words representation for
each of the records so that's how you do
in pi torch you're initially your data
set class you're reading your data you
do count vectorizer on it that's from SK
learn so that turns it already into the
bag of words and then it generates this
is basically your vocabulary and then
the reverse vocabulary which is
basically from from index to token and
from token to index and your sequences
is basically what your training data is
so in the end that's this bag of words
representation and your labels is the
target that you want to predict you so
ideally your prediction is very close
it's almost the same as this is your one
target and then of course you need to
write these two functions that to either
index by the item I get the item right
by the index or get the size by length
so then I just loaded in and we can see
few examples of that yeah
okay
yeah you can interrupt any time when
you're running the notebook is there is
any problem or confusions around that so
that's how our model would want right we
want a very simple feed-forward network
where the input is our bag of words and
then to predict the class that's the map
yeah
right
so that's what what is wrote over here
is what this graph is so we take our
input we do some matrix multiplication
and we do activation and we do a few of
those until we hit the output yeah and
when I wrap it into this this thing
which is a sigmoid that it gives that
skills your output into between 0 and 1
and we'll use that as the properly
prediction now we define the loss and
then use you call your optimizer saying
please step we do backward propagation
and then we call our optimizer saying
please take a step after all the
parameters so that we're going down
hills and over here it is how you define
your neural net
same as what I showed before so you
initialize it you can fit a few
parameters the size of my vocabulary and
then also each of the layers how many
neurons I wanted to have you always give
it a number like by power of two 512
256 etc actually give it's actually more
optimized in this way and when you're
calling my model pi torturous tell will
tell you what kind of like model
structure you have over here we have a
very simple model that we have a
vocabulary of 3000 and then we try to
project that to a size of 128 and then
further down on a second layer until on
the output layer we want to predict 1 or
0 ok
and this also you see before we
initialize it with what's called a
binary cross-entropy so it's a it's also
built-in you can also use cross-entropy
which automatically says assumes this
multi class but in this case since we
only have 1 and 0 I use binary binary
cross-entropy and then you call your
optimizer in this case is a dynamic one
called Adam so it's going to know by
this is
dynamically change your learning rates
so that we're taking a step you're not
over crossing so I would say that if you
call by parameters only returns you all
the variables that trainable so would
work but it's like a standard way of
doing that so that you make sure that
none of those static values got feed
into it and got changed yeah true yeah
okay yeah and they were giving a
learning rate of initial learning rate
but I would adapted to it each round it
runs okay then you call them Auto that
train which basically just tells your
model that you're in a training mode and
over here you can run inside it so we
specifically do only ten rounds and it
is quite a small data set so when you
run it it doesn't take seconds to get
the output yeah we train it for ten
rounds and each of those loaders will
give me a batch of size of 512 right
yeah anyway it gives gives me back the
first batch batch by batch so for each
of those batches I then do the same
thing that's basically one round over
there over the model I said zero my
gradients on the parameters I give it a
four pass so that generated my
prediction I use the prediction versus a
target get the loss and then this is
basically the lost number and use that
number to do differentiation backwards
and then you take a step to towards the
right direction and then this is
basically just recording how our loss
goes down throughout each round right
here you see the output so it starts
from point seven and goes down okay yeah
we can see a few examples so here we
give it a text and then we tokenized
that text we do pre-processing over here
by the this thing so that turns it into
a bag of words and then we use that to
say please give me a prediction output
and giving the output and which is
freedom to just ignore to get the
prediction and then let's see like if we
say like it's more than 50% that it says
is a positive then we print positive
otherwise negative yeah let's see a few
examples so for instance here is this
poor excuse for movies terrible etc is
very likely is a negative review and the
output of it that's the sigmoid and then
the other one cool cat save the kid is a
symbolic masterpiece right and it might
must be like interesting intriguing or
these kind of words and it is a positive
sentiment yeah so there's a few examples
you can write your own as well give it a
text and then try to use this this
method to get the prediction yeah that's
pretty much it basic intro and then yeah
so then it's got to talk about
continuous representations right now we
have a discrete one but then how do you
know the cinnamons between words yeah
[Music]
okay so a big thing that made deep
learning for LP possible was this idea
of the embedding so before with an LP
words were always treated categorically
like with this one hot representation or
something like that but we really want
it to be that we have like a similar
representation if there's a similar
meeting we want to be able to have this
property so we can come up with this
idea of the embedding where we have for
every word we have this vector so you
look down words per word and there's
this some kind of representation and we
would hope that with whatever
representation we come up with that we
can have properties that synonyms would
have a similar factor representation so
you can see kind of like right here the
words on and D both have relatively
similar vectors so that's what we want
so this is also how you can create
many layer and pi torch so you can
basically have PI torch just learn
embeddings on the fly while you're
training but let's go into how we can
train these and betting's ourselves or
how people train them so words avec I
won't go into the details of the
algorithm but I'll go over the
high-level concept of what it is so we
kind of have this assumption with words
avec where we have words that are
similar in location we'll have some kind
of similar meaning and if we get enough
text we can imagine that we can get this
really good representation of words
based on its neighbors so the basic idea
is that there's a neuro network best
trained and it's going to predict a
target word given some kind of context
word so if we imagine we just pick a
random word in here then we pick another
random word within maybe ex neighbors
that we can have say that these two are
a training example for these two words
have some kind of meaning connection so
it's called a skip grand model and
there's also the first quote that you
should know a word by the company it
keeps so that's like the idea of the
context giving the way the meaning so
the traditional vector pre-trained and
betty's that people will use for these
in alchemy models is glove this from
Stanford this is one of the pictures
from their paper so this really cool
thing with what they did with this words
avec is that they're able to create
these representations for every word and
they actually have a semantic meaning
behind them so of course the vectors
they train are either like 50
dimensional or 100 m inch or 300 I
mentioned all you can there's an
algorithm called t-sne which will take
these high dimensional representations
and plot them into 2d an approximation
algorithm so we can see that we have
these words plotted here and we can even
see that they have some kind of semantic
geometry to them so for example we can
take the word King subtract man and plus
woman and that's gonna approximately
equal Queen so these with these kind of
metaphors if that's how we can know that
the algorithm is working correctly so
you can see on the bottom right you see
King and then bomb laugh you see man
if you woman on top left and then if you
do the vector operation you can get
Queen that's pretty cool so there's also
a way we can visualize and he's glob
embedding so there's this really cool
repo with this user and I'd be hard to
see from here we can basically so what
they did was they took these high
dimensional word embeddings and they
decided that they wanted to plot them in
3d way so you can kind of like zoom
around and these are all from gloves so
if we stop here oh gosh yeah maybe I'll
get you hard to see well you can kind of
see each of these nodes but on your own
time you can look at that it's super
cool you can see like words like mother
father sister brother will all be in
their own little cluster countries in
Africa will all be in their own little
cluster also you'll have whatever kind
of topic you'll be able to see where it
fits in this 3d space and it's really
cool to have this visualization of how
the and that needs work okay okay so
he's also embedding this notebook that
you can check out we'll go as in detail
with the other one but basically a cool
takeaway from this one is how can we
load these blog vectors easily so
traditionally I call them sit out and
people would like grab this file name
from the Stanford page they'll open up
the file name and like split each line
that's a little bit tedious so what we
can use is we can use this library in
Python called magnitude which will load
them in an efficient way called pipe
agna tude
you can download this file and two
seconds place on my internet speed and
it didn't take very long and you can
query a list of words and then get the
glove back there's nice and easy a cool
thing also is that we can do these
vector operations on the word so if we
define a cosine similarity function and
we get the glove vectors for each
- the two words that we want to compare
we can actually get the cosine
similarity so we can just get some
random words like dog and cat and see
they have a high similarity and like
treating cat lower you know I'm king and
queen higher so you can kind of do these
kind of similarities between two words
and then also a show here we have the
TSM II plot so I just thought of two
categories of things I thought up of
animals and of household objects that I
just listed them oops listen them all
out here so I just on the top of my head
and then we can use the t-sne algorithm
to be able to then plot these in two
dimensions and you can see that there's
a very clear difference
so the t-sne algorithm has no idea
what's what's a dam or what's a house
with object galaxies are these vectors
of numbers and it's able to plot them in
such a way that there's a very clear
distinction in the way these vectors are
formed that separate them that's the
general idea
yeah
okay so now let's talk about Arnaz so we
think about what sequences so because
the think of like weather patterns so it
might be sunny two days and rain then we
have Sun and rain
music it's also a sequence where we have
something and then the next note is
predicted from the previous note and
text is of course also a sequence so the
good thing that is in common is that
they all have some kind of time axis so
it's some kind of pattern or some kind
of distribution that involves over time
so things appear everywhere
yeah so neural networks up to this point
didn't really have a good way of
handling sequences like this because it
will all just look at like everything
together and wouldn't be able to have
this kind of idea of what came before
and what's gonna come after so when we
get a recurrent neural network we have
this basically it has a loop that feeds
into itself so at every time step the
network feeds some kind of state back
into itself so we can look at the basics
of aren't in so we can basically take
this which is a representation and
unfold it per time so if we unfold it
for time we can see we had for every
input X we can see that input here so
it's like for every input X we give it
to our kernel network at a time step and
it passes a hidden state on to the next
so it's able to maintain these so it's
input hidden state and then these are
some output so yeah at each signs that
the Arnim unit uses the previous hidden
state and the input at that time step to
predict a new hidden state and also an
output so the general function of how we
describe this is that H sub T is the
hidden state we have some kind of
function that takes in the previous
hidden state and also our X of T our
input and this is parameterised by theta
so it has kind of weights to it as well
so we have also different types of arnaz
so we can have okay so one to one this
is just like no iron and this is just
like a classic neural network like a
feed-forward Network for image
classification we can have a one-to-many
so this is where you have like one input
image and then we generate some kind of
caption to that so it's one to many
so these blue on here are like every
output you have many-to-one where we
take a movie review which is like
several words and then we have one
output like is it a positive review or
is it a negative review I mean can have
many too many so this is like machine
translation text generation so we have
like an input like translation in
English or we have English and we
translate it to German for example and
then we have minutes and mini so you can
also have video classification on a
frame level so we have a something
that's called the vanishing gradient
problem so with traditional rnase is
traditional earnings had a really hard
time managing these long-term
dependencies what it would do is it
would forget things really quickly like
over like four times in steps it would
forget something they had a really hard
time with that so we can imagine when we
do the back propagation every one of
these we had a gradient be multiplying
right and because of the chain rule so
if we have some gradient early on that
has like a value of like less than one
this is going to get multiplied and
multiplied and multiplied by multiplied
is gonna get really tiny so this is
called the vanishing gradient so the
effect of this for an RNN is that words
that appear really far back are gonna
have it like a negligible impact on
later on if they had a small gradient
this is really bad so like you can
imagine you can say something like hairy
my best friend and classmate from my
childhood back in Oklahoma is here so we
asked our network okay tell us who is
here and they're gonna say Oklahoma
because that was like right before so
tarnan is not able to really comprehend
like these kind of something that's
really long back that we need to take
into account for answering our question
another problem is this exploding
gradient so this is vanishing we have
exploding so it's similar it's just the
instead of our being less than 1 our
grades being less than 1 we have it be
larger than 1 for early time sets and
it's get multiply and multiply multiply
multiply it's gonna get really huge so
one possible remedy is you can
radiant clipping so you can say I want
the max or min value my gradient to be
these certain values and it's been like
cap it out
but there's still this fundamental
problem with our n ends is that they
have a really hard time handling these
long term dependencies so this is going
to motivate the discussion of different
art and architectures so this is our
simple RNN that we just kind of talked
about a bit so it's it's pretty yet so
simple then there's an LS TM which you
probably have heard of so it kind of
solves the screening problem by
remembering things
so it has these certain gates that help
it remember and we also have a GRU which
happened after the LOC M which was
basically a simplification of the LSP M
by having less operations that made it
train faster without suffering too much
performance loss okay so the symbol R in
it is with this equation so it's really
just we take a previous in estate we
take the 10 X X of T our input we do we
have weights and we just do the dot
product and atoms together apply a 10 H
to normalize them between negative 1 and
1 and then then we that's how we get our
new hidden state ok so you'll actually
see us on the next slides I want to
discuss it if you see this notation with
the little circle it's just this is just
like an element-wise product so the
fancy name is it's Hadamard product but
it looks like this so it's just it's the
way matrix multiplication you might
think it works at the beginning of your
math class okay so with Ellis Ian it
gets a bit more complicated with the
implementation
we'll go through each part okay
so C is our cell state H is our hidden
state X is our input and then we have
our next hidden state we have our next
cell state okay so this first one in the
cyan we have our previous cell site so
this is basically like a fast fast lane
so because Arden's had a hard time
taking what's previous and taking old
memories and
pulling them to the beginning are to the
current prediction this kind of provides
like a fast lane for the lsdm to
transfer information so we have
different operations that will
contribute to this fast lane so this
vessel a basically it only has a
multiplication or addition so it has
either stuff zeroing out or added to it
so it's it can help with maintaining old
memories better so this gate right here
is called oh forget gate so this one is
this F sub C so yeah so the picture here
corresponds with the equations here so
they're equivalent but it can be easier
for some people to see one other people
to see the other so with the forget gate
here the main idea between this forget
gate is that it will make it so that
this is a sigmoid here sigmoid scales it
between 0 and 1
oh yeah so I'm sorry so each of these
ones in green is its own neural network
so each of these it's like a little mini
neural network there each parameterize
by weights so you see W sub F u sub F
our Bost parameters of this neural
network here and though because I you
serve eyes what's here so these these
are each parameterize by weights so what
this one does is it tells our network
whether we want to forget something or
not so it's gonna output with the
sigmoid 0 between 0 1 so 1 is like close
to remember everything serious like
let's forget this thing so an example of
where this is useful is like if we're
talking about like if we're like having
a model that's trying like predict like
the gender of someone with like their
name then we might say when we get a new
name let's forget the gender pronoun
that we were using before to like start
over for this new person for example so
that would be a really nice use for this
forget gate here next let's talk about
is the update gate that's right here so
what this basically does is it will take
our previous hidden state and it'll
apply a cygwin and it will say which
parts of our previous hidden state do we
want to like focus on I guess we've also
have @nh so this takes it this basically
just scales our head and States this is
like the input and this is like what we
want to remember
ever input and then we add these to our
fast lane for our cell state and then we
also have this output gate which is this
Oh sup T here and this is basically how
we want to compute our next hidden state
okay so this is all pretty complicated
but the overall idea is that these LS
teams are pretty good at remembering
stuff that happened long ago
much better than simple Arnon so a nice
little so something you might wonder is
why do we need to have like this cell
state and also this hidden state like
because they're both kind of doing
similar kind of things they're both
taking the previous output and then like
predicting something new so that was the
gr you actually doesn't have this cell
state so they simplified it by just
having this hidden state and they modify
this in and state so it's similar it's
just like a simplification so this is
the update gate so they actually for
this LCM they had this forget and update
but they both kind of do similar things
someone's like oh forget these things
the other ones like let's remember these
things so that's not super nice because
they're both kind of doing like the same
thing so let's have one update gate
right here and then we also have a reset
gate so the update gate tells us what we
want to remember or forget and then the
reset gate oh sorry yeah this one's a
reset gate but yeah um so the overall
this is just a simplification of it so
the nice thing about here is the
previous LCM has a lot more operations
you can see there's like a lot more
stuff going on here if you count them
and this has a lot less so the effect of
this is that this is a lot quicker for a
training and what they found that
there's a similar performance okay so
let's talk about the PI torch aren't in
how we describe our model for defining
our aren't in so we first take our class
and we inherit from in an OP module like
before we must define and init and a
forward and then for our in it we also
had to inherit from the parent class we
define an embedding layer as our encoder
we define an RNN as our GRU and we also
define decoder which will take the
output of the GRU shape and project it
onto the shape that our
target so if we're doing like
classification will want one if we want
to distinguish between three classes
we'll put three and then we define
forward so four words like how we want
to take our inputs that were given to us
and then make really transform the do
some transformations to make them into
our output so we first apply an encoder
on our input we get encoded we get an
RNN so this takes an input in a previous
hidden state so to get that hidden state
we actually call up here outside the
small definition and it hidden and then
we'll get this hidden state and that's
the stuff that is right here then for
our output we apply a decoder and then
we return an output in the hidden state
and we basically call this in a loop for
a per item in our input okay
so let's look at a since mint text
classification example yeah okay yeah
yeah so this is an arn tend to do so
before we were doing it backwards
through our text classification so it
was not taking into account position of
the words at all and for this one we'll
do it Arnon so for example for one way
that this could do better is if you say
like not good you know you need the
position to know that what that means
like you need to know that not up here
before good if it was in a different
ordering you know or if it was unordered
it might have a different connotation
okay like if it said not good versus not
bad you know it's it's hard to it's
about you going backwards you can't
distinguish this as well yeah so basic
idea will use a gru here and we defined
an RN n so this RN n has an encoder with
a embedding layer we define we mesh
define a gru here and then we have a
decoder so it's very similar to the code
snippet you saw yeah so it's doing so
instead of actually taking in the hidden
state would take send the entire since
that's again one input at a time
for loop we'll take all the inputs
together and then apply them all
together to the RNN so this will do it
like this passing of the hidden state
like under the hood
they said I think like explicitly doing
it yeah
so we have our inputs we have an encoder
the GRU decoder will get locked lockets
logits back I guess
and then the logics and the target you
can compare them with your criteria
which is a loss function which would
tell you how your model is doing and
then you get lost and then perform green
to sit on so we accentuate BCE with la
gets lost which will do a binary cross
entropy and then optimizer you define
with Adam and then similar to before we
just have another training loop it's
actually I think nearly identical to the
one before
yeah but we get perform we see the model
has learned something and then we can
see it similar to before like give
either negative sentiment or positives
and submit to these different reviews
so the next notebook we're gonna look at
is for character generation so we want
to look at like given some input
characters we can also have our targets
as like one time step off so for ever
you like Hugh will predict you you would
predict I see you know it so we do this
like one-off setup so we can look at
this model to help understand what's
happening so we take our yeah we take
our input and we take our hidden okay
yeah I see yeah so it's basically for
every time step of the input will apply
to GRU to it and we'll pass the hit into
itself okay so let's open this it's just
the time step so you always want to give
the previous line the next one you could
do also so you have it like yeah okay so
it's a teacher forcing so you want to
always have the previous one predict the
next one model concept so basically
we'll try to train a model that if I
said I am and it's gonna predict the
next word so I'm using my word so you
can use a very long text like Nava or
somehow and I always shot it by Windows
so you give a few words predict the next
one and then shove the like move your
window a bit and then you train like
this that's what a language model is and
it's okay so this is text pre-processing
where you have our data set class we get
it load our data we get a vocab size we
make something that will turn characters
and the season the indices back the
characters yeah so and then we turned
them into it so we have for every input
will have the list of integers that
describe its position in the dictionary
so we have an RNN model here so we'll
take our yeah so I guess is very similar
to the one before so this one we
actually do to carry the hidden here so
instead of hashing like all the inputs
at once and then having one target we
said do
so that we give it one character then we
give it then a yes we give it one
character you get the hens date and then
we calculate the loss per character so
we keep feeding like the correct answer
back to the model instead of playing the
model like carry its own state so that
we can see this in the training loop so
for inputs targets in our batch so for
every character in our input we will
apply our will we will apply the model
to that one character and then we'll
have our model actually applied the
criterion on that one output that it
predicted versus that correct character
output so that's why there's like this
one off here yeah so this training loop
and then so the results aren't going to
look amazing because it was just like a
really simple model but you can see
since as for our generate weight-loss
articles but you can see that it's it's
generated during like English looking
text that sounds about like weight loss
you know so we'll actually do a text
generation after this that would be
considerably better but this is the
simple model that's easier to understand
yep
if you do drop out or what they do this
model doctrine you do model eval and
that will like turn off your drop out
and everything yeah so if you were doing
in this loop if you were doing both a
training set and then also a validation
step what I usually do is have separate
functions one train and then what
another one fouled eight and at the
Train one I'll have a model train and
the validate one of model eval and then
it'll make it so that the drop so for
the evaluation but it will turn off the
dropouts and everything yep but yeah
they show your first simplicity but yeah
okay yeah so this just generate some not
not passable text but it's doing
assuming this job and then will later do
better next generation so a short recap
we see backup words which is a discrete
representation just like what's the
composition of words within this text
then we say we don't know synonyms and
we talked about embeddings which
basically projects the meaning of the
word by taking into account of its
context where does it normally show up
and we found out that okay we can use
this embeddings to to into the are nouns
that you just see and we can also create
meaningful vectors for the whole text so
we feeding a sentence and then the
hidden layer is going to accumulate
what's the previous word it takes so
this representation versus the bag of
words backwards doesn't take an account
of the position of the words right so
you just take say the occurs three times
and so on on and that does take into
account so if we take the last hidden
State it actually can contains all the
the ordering meanings of the previous
word Plus that you have feeding the
embeddings so it takes an account of
meaning of the word plus the position
and we use that for language modeling
basically predicting the next word or
next character etc we can also produce
something like sequence models that's
more useful for instance like
translations we're taking a sequence of
English text and can you turn those
representation into a vector that can
use that to omit translation for like
French or German yep and that's what
we're gonna talk about next so the most
simple one out of the sequence models
for every sequence to sequence so our
input is a sequence of text say English
and then we feed that into encoder you
can imagine that like a simple iron or
GRU
so by each step the reason the the new
word as a new input construct the next
head and stay with the previous hidden
state together and it goes on until it
can turn the whole input sequence into
this context vector you see here and
then this this pass on to the decoder
where the decoder takes position by
position so say this is my input context
which conveys all the sequence of
information of the source can i generate
your target one step at a time that
actually represents as the translation
that's output so here is an English to
German translation and both of these
encoder and decoder can be recursive
neural nets so you can do two RNs one
reads in the input one spits out the
output okay we can look at some
different applications of sequence to
sequence so machine translation is one
from one kind of text through the other
language we can do question answering or
chat for someone ask a question someone
answer that the milk model answers you
can do date formatting
or you can do also speech-to-text or
speeches also like audio format you can
cut it into small chunks and I use that
as timestamps and I use that to predict
what's the text for each of those chunks
or few chunks and what we do at Scout B
we do name to domain for instance we
sometimes see on a websites their
company name we use NER to extract those
company names before it's very important
to know the website of the company so
can we use the input sequence of those
names to predict what its website is to
predict its domain and suppose sequences
so yeah I see the examples here for the
first one is translation from English to
German the other ones QA like how are
you I'm fine
and the other one is date formatting so
you if you have a data set that contains
a lot of like 10 9 really like free text
like dates it can come with different
kind of format like this Tufts of july
2019 or different formats can we all
normalize it into a sequence output of
that or in our case a name to domain
given the name of the website can we per
day actually their URL where the domain
of the website so it's actually quite
useful if you train it well and then
it's gonna do good predictions on that
so here's a animation which from some of
that source there's all these blogs
about great animations that you can
really understand well with a few 5 to
10 minutes so each time step from the
input it feeds into the encoder imagine
the RN that we talked about before so
say your french french input from the
first word input it emits the hidden
state and your RN goes on the second
input with the previous headed state
generates a new hidden state etc what
you do is you take the last hidden state
which you assume contains all the
information from the previous tokens you
give that to the decoder and then
decoder takes a time
my times then considering its new input
from the previous word and then your
context to generate this translation yep
that's basically how it works and then
you can think about both eyes are an N
and how the model will connect together
oh sure and it's thick yeah this is also
another animation more in detail she
like from hidden one to hidden to two
hidden three and that's our output the
last hidden state and use that to emit
the next translation the next word for
the translation okay on top we want to
add something called attention yeah
and this attention mechanism actually
boost this model quite a lot so if you
have a plane let's say else TM for your
encoder and then I'll stand for your
decoder although I was TM compared to
our NN captures long-term dependencies
much better but you only feed the last
input like the last hidden state to
there if we go back we only feed the
last hidden state into the decoder and
in ironin state like in your last day
that means the words that's most recent
is actually most important so some of
the techniques they try is like
bi-directional they read the text from
this side versus like both directional
and try to feed those contacts into it
but still both sides like that the start
and the end got captured the most so it
doesn't actually tells you if I'm on
this position of the decoder which of
the word is the most important this
alignment right from my input
I am Jeffery and back to a to a German
input if I'm an M which we my around
that second times them which were should
I focused most from my input state and
that's what the idea of attention is
so there's two difference from attention
to water a simple sequence to sequence
with our ends or our stems first that
instead of just feeding the last hidden
state we take all the hidden States from
the source so all the sequence hidden
state outputs we all feed into the
decoder and then secondly the decoder
each times then when it's gonna predict
is going to look at all these previous
context like these are the single
vectors that on each of the time step
and you say which one of that is the
most important and then the end this is
actually a alignment problem right I
take my output sequence my position and
I look at all these previous input
timestamp and and say which input is the
most important for me right now to to
make the next prediction and that's the
idea of attention and yeah here we have
a more detail don't worry how to the
wait are actually calculated but and
your encoder stages is exactly the same
as the sequence to sequence or a simple
R and then at each time step you have
this output so say our input is three
words this is I love PI torch for
instance yeah I love high torque each
represented as this hidden state H 1 H 2
and H 3 and then your encoder at each
step it takes this output like the
previous output token end and that's it
it gets the new hidden state of that are
in and then use that so that's actually
your previous word representation and
your target you take your target and
then you compare that to all the hidden
state oh yeah oh yeah hey
yeah so it goes on until it says that
the most likely next word is the end
token so when you're training it you
give it a star token and you get it Pat
it with the end token so that when
you're training a nose okay this is my
start that's my end so at which lens is
most likely that has to end in reality
when we were training it we also give it
like a maximum length so we said that
this model is not going to go on forever
if it's like go out of state so I don't
know yeah so you see over here that's
what does at this step so it takes this
hidden state from the decoder like the
turn the previous target words
representation it compares with all the
previous hidden state and do the scoring
they use the score to say which are the
ones that is most important so that's
the one you that's the one you use for
weighting discoloring the lighter it is
the more emphasis is the song so you
scale your input into different you
scale your input basically of all these
vectors and then you sum it so that your
context vector right now at each time
step of the decoder is going to look
different because your encoder is always
the same like encoder gives you the same
input but then for each step of your
decoder it should gives you a different
emphasis on which one so actually it
does the scoring that's on top and then
use that to predict the next word so we
feed that together with the hidden state
through a feed-forward network with 10h
scale it and then the output is
basically a sauce with four softmax yeah
so we'd be on your output layer you
project your hidden size of this two
times the hidden size which take an
educator you project that to the
vocabulary space and you do a softmax
which one after next word is most likely
and that's I'm one step and then you can
do a second step the second step
basically takes it takes into the
account of the previous hidden state
here and then at this step that compares
out of all the known contacts vectors
which one are the most important at this
position guess again
spits out the next one that's overall
idea so why is it performing much better
is basically it actually gets all the
context from the input that's one thing
and also at each step is able to focus
on different part of the the context
that's most relevant for next prediction
and those are the so-called
encoder/decoder intention is you can
think about an attention here as an
alignment task yeah I take my decoder
turn Stein step I compared to all the
encoders and tell me which part should I
pay attention to yeah
so attention determines which part of
the interest input sequence is most
important for my time step at decoder
that's why it's called encoder decoder
intention because it compares the
encoder sequence versus the decoder
sequence so over here you have the
encoder sequence all of those and then
you have one decoder sequence it tries
to come up with a score and then you
feed it into overall this is the softmax
of this rule so it says out of all these
inputs from the encoder on this this
timestamp what's the one that's most
important so for instance from English
to French English is our input and then
the first time step is that the is the
most important and this is actually from
the original paper that that that does
that they give a boost on the blue score
of translations this this matrix is what
you see here of alpha TS there's
actually the attention weight so so each
of the cell is scaled by the softmax to
between 0 and 1 and if you
this should be equal to one over here as
your son by rose and actually when you
look at the plot you can see how the
alignment goes right so it's not
necessary that each time step like x
times 3i correspond to time step of
encoder it actually learns it by itself
says maybe your language ordering is
different between two languages so when
I'm when I'm here
your p.m. that correspond to here in
European with a different different
position but actually give it a big
boost so it says this token or this
context from the encoder is very
important important on this time set
that's why I gives a very accurate
output up on this position after decoder
so you take your weight and you scale by
your input by this weight and I've
summit this is what we see before after
that you have scaled by different colors
and then you sum that into this context
vector and that's the context vector
specifically at this time so that's why
you see CT after decoder and you use
that to generate the attention which
gives you a prediction in the end that's
how the cell works okay that's how you
do it in Python so at the previous slide
you see the score before you do the wave
the score and there's different kind of
method you can do scoring for that you
can do some matrix multiplication
between a decoder encoder etc there are
different ones you can see family of
those here we're using the most original
one from the paper where you actually
transform both the encoder input and the
current decoder hidden state and then
you concatenate them and scale by them
scale by 10h which is a score that tells
you how much they are aligned and I used
that to fit into a soft max to scale
them between 0 & 1 that gives a
description distribution among the
different input context and then use
that to scale your encoder output which
is basically your different
encoder position context into the real
context vector at this stage you want
yeah yeah that's how you do attention
with sequence of sequence in M PI torch
but a few researchers at Google they
found out that actually retention is
what matters right so your sequence to
sequence although it gives you these
different positions at each time step
but with attention you're able to say
what are all the alignments between the
input and output sequence for each of
the output it actually looks at all the
input and say what's the most important
so that's why this paper comes out
attention is what your what you need
it's all unique it comes from one and a
half years ago it's one that really
changes the game of NLP what they said
is that we can use a lot of attentions
we just use attentions to align on the
input text among even amount of words
and if we do that we stack all these
encoder/decoder we stack all these like
attentions together it's going to become
a an encoder and I call also stack all
these attentions together that becomes a
decoder can I just use that and get rid
of ireland's at all okay I stack a lot
of those attentions which actually tells
me all the alignments between text and
one one thing one of the good thing is
that super paralyzed able because you
have all these attentions which you can
train on each of those separate GPUs and
also they initiate something called a
multi head which is basically initially
initializing a lot of different
attentions each of those attentions you
can think about like an ensemble model
where you each of those I'm one of the
ensembles attentions is able to learn
alignments within its own text and it's
like what they said is much faster to
train in reality they did it in a very
beefy machine on a very B femoral
and that's what generated all these
coming forward like open a is
transferred the transformer model etc
those are like extremely large machines
extremely large models but they're very
useful for transfer learning etc okay
let's go a bit into the detail of how
transformers work in the end it's a
stack of encoder and decoder similar
yeah the only thing changes is that each
of those like encoders does is not a
Arnon anymore they're just they're just
all these things called self attention
their attention selves you stack all
these together that actually what it
does is it creates an alignment between
its own text so my input text say it's
an English text like I love PI torch at
each of the steps it actually aligns
within yourself like I which were that
correspond to most likely within my
input text and a second position third
position etc that's what that's what it
does inside the encoder set and then a
decoder step it does similar things it
takes the target output feed it through
the attention and then plus that the
attention output from the encoder and
then code determines which kind of
output should I generate for each of
those positions so it does similarly
encoders decoders fashion English to
German yeah what it what it actually
looks like is inside each of those
encoder and each of those decoder is two
parts one is something called self
alignment this is what you take the same
sentence and you say of each of the
position each of those word positions
which have the other words that it most
relates to you take that representation
use Fida through a normal fee for
network and then you and then you stack
them up right like in the previous slide
we see a stack of encoders together and
a stack of decoder imagine you've just
have one then
you have a representation of the encoder
and then you send it to the encoder
decoder attention and here you have the
decoder self attention which is the
representation of your decoder step
together this encoder decoder attention
similar to the attention we talked about
before takes those books input and then
predict the next word okay okay cool so
that's how the equation looks like in
reality you take your input and then you
generate something called a query a key
and a value yeah and why is it called
self attention is because your query and
your key is actually the same same
sentence same sequence in the previous
life decoder encoder you take your probe
your key then is your decoders sequence
and then sorry your Curie is your
decoder sentence and then your key is
your encoder sentence and you try to
align decoder with the encoder with self
attention is actually looking at the
same sequence and said my query is
myself at this timestamp
my key is all the inputs context of of
the same same sentence and which of
those is most important so does this dot
product of the transpose and it scales
by the value to generate this so this is
actually your you can think like your
encoder representation out of the self
detention we're also decoder works if
you take the same sentence and just want
to know which of the words we think that
correspond to the other and what they do
is they do multi-head which is basically
each of those layers is one attention
and then generate multiple ones of those
does act like a Zombo kind of method
that allows the model to learn actually
different alignments between its own
self attention so yeah I'm not gonna go
into detail and that's all the overall
model looks like from the paper and
yeah I'm gonna skip through these two
slides you can look at it later but
let's see how actually works so over
here we have a easier one
so transformer is like a lot of and
Sambo's which doesn't train like scale
well right now here so over here what we
show is a sequence to sequence model
with attention this one I show before so
the attention is basically
encoder/decoder attention okay how you
prepared the data is in similar fashion
to inherit by the data set and you pat
it this is where you want to Pat the
sequences so that is all in the same
length that's the start of the token and
of the start of the sequence end of the
sequence token and for unknown words so
you pre-process your text into those
tokens remove the we're words and they
generate those sequence of indices which
represents your input and output
sequences and then here is our model
definition so similar diagram before
what you would do is you're you initiate
encoder for it which basically takes the
embedding embedding is your input word
into the embedding fils it into the a
RNN or in this case it's a GRU and when
you do the forward pass it takes the the
previous hidden state and spits out the
next it's the plain RNN then you define
another decoder which in this case
similar in the first part which is the
GRU like the the recurrent neural net
taking into the account of the
embeddings from the decoder and then
feed it through attention weights and
your and when you do the for a pass it
takes both the encoder output with the
current hidden state output from from
the GRU and then try to scale to get the
score and use that score to to scale
your attention weights and use that to
predict output yeah that's the to class
encoder and decoder and then you
pass it on together so you initiate a
new model saying it's a Antonio decoder
we think that you call your encoder you
call your decoder and each of the four
paths you each of those four four paths
for us here when you call the model it
feeds the data into encoder generate the
hidden hidden context which is basically
your contacts at that time step and then
takes the decoder hidden state together
with that to generate the next next word
prediction yep and then you can do
training similar it's similar fashion
your initiate your model you do it's
exactly the same thing here and then
here are a few examples that generated
so I was really proud of that I don't
speak French I cannot tell how good this
is but this is only like one layer right
so is one layer of encoder one layer of
decoder and we trained it for only ten
that box and all we say like this is
kind of probably yeah I see like for the
words I know that looks pretty much
decent what you see is from the decoder
if you say that as I can read them very
random sequence of text then is maybe
it's not relearning something but if it
actually allows to something similar to
French
the idea was we would make very simple
notebooks that are easy to understand
rather than of course for training on
production the first thing is that you
do more pre-processing so that you
stream down to the domains I really want
to write right and the other thing is we
probably will pie it up being a more
beefy models that that predicts much
better because this is only like train
on 10 times on one layer if you imagine
the free stack of three layers and I
give it like a several thousand round a
box of training that will become much
more like convincing at the output
actually true yeah so you can use an
existing data data set that gives you
the score of blue yeah
yeah so so you do when you do
pre-processing you already like
lowercase remove software etc alright
those are stripped off what you can do
to get in the end
character model especially it's easy to
just leave and all the special
characters all the capitalizations if
you have character level model the
downside is that your sequence will be
much longer in this case right because
you are though
single characters but then you wouldn't
have the problem of unknown unknown
tokens and then you can leave in even
caps because your size is just gonna be
caps and small letters and some numbers
etc and I was still for translation I'm
still lowercase them if we are doing
like word level because you don't want
the position of that word I have to
become like a new vocab or somehow right
so you want those two like worse to be
very high very high and overlapping so
that actually captures to which position
that should generate that word the best
but I guess you can do some
pre-processing for your predictions as
well that makes that into something that
can be seen as a proper text all right
all right
okay just fast-forward to the end slide
and we'll just leave it there
this one
you